phenotyping algorithm
is very important in supporting
genome-wide association study
what is a genome-wide association study
it's an approach that involves scanning
biomarkers such as single nucleotide
polymorphism
or snips from dna of many people in
order to find genetic variation
associated with a particular disease
field phenotypes
once new genetic associations are
identified researchers can use that
information to develop better strategies
to detect and treat and prevent diseases
so how are genomic white association
studies conducted
to run a genomic white association study
or gwas
we first identify the disease phenotypes
then group the participants into these
two groups cases
and these are people with disease
phenotypes
and controls those are similar patient
without the disease phenotype
then we need to obtain dna samples from
all these participants
from dna samples we can use lab machines
to quickly survey each participant's
genomes for genetic variation
which are called single nucleotide
polymorphism or snip
if certain genetic variation have found
to be significantly more frequent in the
people with the disease phenotypes
compared to people without the disease
phenotype
these variations are said to be
associated with the disease
we do this by computing the frequencies
of snips on the cases
and on the controls then based on the
frequency
we calculate the odds ratio from there
we can calculate the corresponding
p-value for the odds ratio
if the p-value is small then we conclude
this variation is significant
the associated genetic variations can
serve as powerful pointers to the region
of the human genome that may cause the
disease
here's an example showing more details
on how the g wass is computed
we first identified the cases and
controls
that is the people with the disease
phenotype and the people without the
disease phenotype
in this case we have four thousand
patients with the disease phenotype and
six thousand patients without the
disease phenotype
then we iterate over all the snips to
compare the relevant frequencies for
instance for snip one for the control
group
we have two thousand six hundred and
seventy six out of six thousand has the
corresponding variation g
at this location and the frequency of g
in this case is forty four point six
percent
in the case group we have two thousand
one hundred and four out of four
thousand with the corresponding
variation g at this location
so the frequency is fifty two point six
percent
if we go through the calculation we'll
find now the p-value is five times ten
to the minus fifteen
which means this is extremely
significant
we can conduct the same calculation on
snip two and find out the p-value here
is zero point three three which is not
significant
to support g was study we need to know
high quality phenotypes on the cases and
controls in order to perform this
calculation
that's why phenotyping algorithm is very
important
as we have shown in the genome-wide
association studies
we need phenotypic data in order to
analyze genomic data
but in general why do we care about
phenotyping algorithms in genomic study
in fact many people argue that we need
rich and deep phenotypic data in order
to analyze genomic data
especially as sequencing technology
improves the cost of generating genomic
data
is dropping so fast over time while the
cost of computing or moore's law cannot
keep up with the improvement of
sequencing technology
which means we'll have more and more
genomic data in near future about many
individuals
however due to the complexity of the
electronic health record
the cost for generating high quality
phenotypic data is actually increasing
while the cost of genomic data is
dropping drastically
that is why we really need to invent
better phenotyping algorithms to reduce
the cost of acquiring high quality
phenotypic data
and to support genomic studies